i love helping people with design and so
i'm excited that we recently got to do a
little
home run right here in our wardrobe
department
we are gonna get a washer dryer and over
there
the styler and that's like this steamer
steamer
unit yeah i mean that feels like having
a dry cleaner
i think we paint every single thing we
can
yeah what do you think i think i know so
emphatically what i like i still like
that me too
it was a clothes call but everyone got
to work quick
and i'm so excited that we teamed up
with lg for this
design by drew we've installed the lg
wash tower
with these center controls it's the
first of
its kind and it gives you room to do so
much more with your space
the wash tower is the perfect touch to
make our little haven
chic yet modern i really can't believe
that we are fortunate enough to work
with professional
grade machinery like this
in our wardrobe closet it's a dream come
true
and i love lg and these
are stunning can you believe
how that unfolded yep i did it again
i hope you had loads of fun like i did
okay all right i'll stop
you